we are living in the age of the playlist
thanks to streaming music services that
give us access to millions of songs
we've got the perfect modern-day mixtape
for almost every activity and now Apple
music which launched last week with over
30 million songs it's supposed to do it
all and even better
humans real live breathing humans are
behind the scenes curating songs and
then feeding us lists based on our music
preferences so it seemed fairly obvious
what I had to do review Apple music in a
playlist this is what my first few days
with Apple music felt like I was
completely lost that's not true
yes the first song on my Apple music
review playlist is led zeppelin's dazed
and confused because that's exactly how
you feel when you start using the
service navigating the two most
important parts of the app the for you
and new sections is like trying to find
your way through a maze
just as Guns and Roses set
finding simple things takes more time
than it should take for example getting
to an artist page from a song and even
when I did figure it out it returned
this error and despite the fun process
of telling the app what music I like it
took about two days for it to stop
thinking I was into country music and
start offering some suggestions that
were really right for me that's when I
started to get into the groove back to
the review once I refine my taste
I started getting lots of playlists and
album recommendations for stuff I love
the only thing I really missed about
Spotify were some of the playlists but
mostly ones made by my friends but
Spotify doesn't have fun Siri tricks
that girl just wants to have fun just
like Cyndi Lauper said play the best
song ever I'm not sure that's the best
song ever but it's going on the playlist
but of course this isn't all free it
costs like Pink Floyd says
apple offers a free three-month trial
and then you have to pay $10 a month
unlike Spotify it doesn't offer a free
full ad-supported version as it stands
right now for $10 a month it's hard for
me to give Apple music my full stamp of
approval
it just has too many bugs and
frustrations in comparison to Spotify on
the other hand it has a great selection
of playlists and integrates right with
iTunes my advice try it out for the
first three months maybe by then Apple
wall fixed up some of the issues it's
like that Rolling Stone song